in our series medical price roulette in
collaboration with clear health costs
we're gonna tell you how some hospitals
are now suing patients to collect their
medical debts
many people use payment plans when
they're hit with bills they can't afford
to pay but we learned some hospitals are
seizing patients tax returns withholding
portions of paychecks and collecting
interest on top of the initial medical
bill our consumer investigative
correspondent and a Werner visited a
community where one Hospital has filed
hundreds of lawsuits Anna they really
want their money it seems yeah yeah you
know you work hard you pay your bills
you try to get ahead but what if an
unexpected medical bill threatens your
livelihood maybe even your health that's
what one couple say they've been going
through at their t-shirt screen printing
company outside Dothan Alabama Darrell
and Casey Roberts are struggling to stay
afloat how's it going slow businesses
are closing people are not making money
like they used to be in 2015 the couple
found they could no longer afford health
insurance Casey said she had a choice
between paying the premiums or taking
her son out of college I wanted my son
to have a better life than I had so what
do you do with a parent who sacrifice
Casey says she'd been healthy but in May
of 2016 she had an attack of severe
abdominal pain I'm well I say I felt
like I was dying I felt like I was dying
her husband rushed her to local flowers
Hospital the doctor told me she needs
needs to have this surgery now her
appendix was about to burst she needed
an emergency appendectomy a few weeks
later the Roberts got the doctor's bills
which didn't surprise them they came to
a little under three thousand dollars
but then the hospital's bill arrived the
charge over fifty two thousand dollars
even with a supposed discount for
uninsured patients like Roberts the
total still came to about $31,000 I
thought was crazy house a house of
Alabama in this area as a health but she
and her husband still paid the hospital
what they could 25 dollars a month for
nearly three years long as I can work
and they'll accept payments we're going
to pay
because everything that we've ever
worked have ahead in life we paid for
yes then in September of 2019 the
hospital sued them for the entire
balance plus interest
the total nearly $37,000 at that point
Casey says I told my husband I wish you
to let me die how can you even think
that I've told my hope in this I said
honey I love you my family but if you
have let me go today you would not be
going through this but what she says she
didn't know was that original thirty one
thousand dollar bill was likely much
higher than what she would have paid if
she'd had insurance and some twenty five
thousand dollars more than what Medicare
would be charged by a hospital on
average for an appendectomy just fifty
eight hundred dollars said likely taken
advantage of people who don't have
insurance and I say you ought to be
ashamed of yourself why would you even
do that
and they're not the only ones flowers
Hospital has sued CBS News found last
year the for-profit Hospital sued more
than fifteen hundred people it's not
clear whether all of the lawsuits were
over medical bills but in one letter to
the court a mother of three wrote with
her $11 an hour paycheck she couldn't
afford the over eleven thousand dollar
bill for emergency treatment
I think it's despicable attorney Christy
Kirkland works on those kinds of cases
at the nonprofit legal services of
Alabama they're going to be paying it
forever or at least for a very very long
time this is not a debt that they're
going to be able to get out from under
very quickly in court Kirkland says
usually the best she can do is get their
payments stretched out over decades what
the attorneys here call the slow bleed
some of these people will be paying five
or ten dollars on their debt until the
day they die we wanted to ask hospital
officials about their prices and all of
those lawsuits on the CBS News we were
told to make an appointment I'd like to
see if he you wanted to speak with us on
camera okay the story okay the next week
they turned us down instead they sent us
a statement saying they try to work with
patients but some individual
refused to engage with us to resolve
their balances litigation is always a
last resort and used only they said for
patients who can afford some level of
payment meanwhile Casey Roberts has a
large painful lump growing on her
shoulder I have not been to a doctor I
can't afford it do you think people like
yourself should be having to make those
choices
it shouldn't be that choice but
unfortunately that's the world we live
in in its statement flowers Hospital
told us it offers interest-free payment
plans for some patients and looks to see
if they're eligible for charity care or
Medicaid the Roberts faced a default
judgment on this in January essentially
a court order to pay but they've since
contacted legal services of Alabama and
attorneys there got that judgment
overturned it doesn't solve their
problem but gives them a chance perhaps
to try to negotiate and by the way you
know the hospital said that some people
refuse to engage that with them but
Casey Roberts says she tried to reach
out she reached out to the hospital
three times they said they would call
her back and she never did get a
callback this was early on when she
feels I'm telling a very different story
Brad Collins that big bill and by the
way we want to hear from people if
you've been sued by a hospital have a
similar story please email us at health
costs at CBS news.com and I realize the
hospital is running a business I get it
but there has to be a better way to do
business when you see people's lives are
on the line just the fact that she has
that lump on her shoulder and doesn't
want to go which by the way mrs. Roberts
you got to go to the doctor about that
is what we said yes you know she
wouldn't want to go I say no the health
care like that should not be a business
and what's particularly learning in this
among the many things that are alarming
is the discrepancy in what they what
they billed for that surgery I mean
every age from fifteen hundred dollars
to thirty one thirty yeah I mean there's
somebody with insurance okay I had a
procedure last year and the you know the
bill that the insurance company
negotiates is like $19,000 but you pay a
thousand dollars yeah so you don't pay
$19,000 on your procedure
you're never gonna pay that amount of
money with insurance which is why the
health care debate is so important as we
get ready to go to the polls
thank you very much Anna